>> Laura: TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
A MAN CAN'T WEAR A MITT CAL
T-SHIRT TO THE GYM -- POLITICAL
T-SHIRT?
THE MOST UNEXPECTED LEGO
CHARACTER OF ALL IS UNVEILED.
JOINING US IS RAYMOND ARROYO,
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLING
AUTHOR.
RAYMOND, A VETERAN IN MISSOURI
WAS FORBIDDEN TO WEAR WHAT?
>> A T SLIRT.
NOW, WE'RE -- T SHIRT.
YOU'VE BEEN REPORTING ON THIS
ALL WEEK.
THE COVINGTON KIDS CALLED OUT
FOR WEARING THE MAGA HATS.
STAFF SERGEANT JAKE TALBOTT SAID
HE WAS WORKING OUT AT THE GYM
WEARING HIS T-SHIRT THAT SAYS
2016 TRUMP FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: HE'S BEHIND.
>> THE OWNER APPROACHED HIM.
>> I WAS WORKING OUT, WHEN I WAS
STARTING, THE OWNER, LIZ, CAME
UP AND SAID THAT MY TRUMP SHIRT
I HAD ON WAS OFFENSIVE, I NEEDED
TO REMOVE TO IT WORK OUT THERE.
IT'S LIKE RACING.
>> HE SAID HE'S WORN THE SHIRT
SEVERAL TIMES BEFORE AND IT'S
NEVER BEEN A PROBLEM.
THE OWNER OF THE GYM RESPONDED
IN A NOW DELETED FACEBOOK POST,
SHEATH I'M DEEPLY SADDENED BY
THE AMOUNT OF HATE THIS EVENT
HAS GARNERED.
>> Laura: EVENT?
>> I WILL PERSONALLY CONTINUE TO
DEFEND MY STANCE FOR TOLERANCE
AND AGAINST HATE, NO MATTER THE
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCE.
I DON'T BELIEVE OUR GYM SHOULD
BE A POLITICAL FORUM FOR ANYONE,
I WANT EVERYONE TO FEEL SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE THERE.
>> Laura: WAIT SECOND, OKAY.
DOES THIS MEAN ALL POLITICAL
MESSAGES AT THIS PARTICULAR GYM,
HAVE TO BE CHECKED AT THE DOOR?
THAT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
SO NOW YOUR FREE SPEECH RIGHTS
AND ABILITY TO BELIEVE WHATEVER
YOU BELIEVE HAS GOT TO BE
CHECKED AT THE GYM WAS YOU'RE A
CONSERVATIVE -- BECAUSE YOU'RE A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> HOW CAN YOU SAY YOU ARE
STRIKING A BLOW FOR TOLERANCE BY
TELLING A GUY YOU CAN'T WEAR
THAT, ARE YOU OFFENDING PEOPLE.
>> Laura: JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
TEASING THAT HE MIGHT MAKE A RUN
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
[LAUGHING]
OR MAYBE A SLOW JOG TO THE WHITE
HOUSE IN 2020.
BUT NOW HIS BIPARTISANSHIP, HIS
PREVIOUS BIPARTISANSHIP IS COME
BAG TO BE BITE HIM IN THE
RADICAL NEW ERA.
>> UNCLE JOE IS MAKING A RUN FOR
THE PRESIDENCY.
BUT CRITICS ARE POUNCING ON HIM,
IN A "NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE,
ENTITLED "JOE BIDEN'S PAID
SPEECH BUOYED THE GOP IN MIDWEST
BATTLE GROUNDS."
IT'S REVEALED, GET THIS, BIDEN
PRAISED A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN, FRED UPTON, AS ONE
OF THE FINEST GUYS I'VE EVER
WORKED WITH SO HELP ME GOD.
SOME ON THE LEFT ARE SAYING THIS
IS A DISQUALIFIER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION, THE
FORMER VEEP IS TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY.
>> I GET IN TROUBLE, I READ IN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THAT ONE OF
MY PROBLEMS IS IF I WERE TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT, I LIKE
REPUBLICANS.
OKAY, WELL BLESS ME FATHER FOR I
HAVE SINNED.
>> Laura: IF HE WERE A LITTLE
BIT YOUNGER, I WOULD SAY HE
WOULD ALREADY, EVERYONE ELSE
MIGHT AS WELL FORGET ABOUT IT
AND NOT RUN.
HE'S LONG IN THE TOOTH.
BUT THAT'S WHY HE'S A THREAT.
BECAUSE HE COULD GET SOME
INDEPENDENT VOTERS WITH THAT
MESSAGE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Laura: AND THE LEFT IS SO
STUPID, THOUGH.
>> AOP AND KAMALA HARRIS AND
BERNIE, JOE BIDEN LOOKS
PRACTICALLY REPUBLICAN, THEY
HAVE PUSHED HIM OUT OF THE
PARTY.
>> Laura: WHAT IF I REVEAL THAT
WHAT HE SAID TO ME?
>> DO IT, GO AHEAD.
>> Laura: GODS'S HONEST TRUTH,
INGRAHAM, OF ALL.
RIGHT WINGERS YOU'RE MY
FAVORITE.
>> I SAW EVERY MOMENT OF IT.
>> Laura: JAY CARNEY WAS HIS
PRESS SECRETARY, HE LOOKED LIKE
HE WOULD DIE.
>> SWEATING IN THE CORNER.
>> Laura: FINALLY, A NEW LEGO IN
TOWN, MY SON IS GOING TO BE VERY
EXCITED, FAMILIAR FACE.
>> NOW, LAURA, THIS IS MORE OF
THE BLIND PARTISANSHIP
CONTINUED.
THE TRAILER OF THE LEGO MOVIE 2.
THE LATEST CHARACTER APPEARS AT
THE END, WATCH FOR HER.
>> EVERYONE SIT DOWN.
♪♪
>> BATMAN.
>> SUPERMAN.
>> A NEW RUTH BADER GINSBERG.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE GOT TO BE
KIDDING ME!
>> THE LEG OWE LEGO MOVIE TAKES
PLACE IN THE IMAGINATION OF THE
BOY'S SISTER, WHERE HER HEROS
SPRING TO LIFE.
THE SIDE BY SIDE OF THE REAL
RUTH BADER.
THESE ARE GOING TO BE ON SALE,
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO BUY THIS,
THE ACTION FIGURE.
>> Laura: THAT'S A TERRIBLE
RENDITION.
I SPENT TIME WITH HER THAT,
LOOKS MORE LIKE JOHN PAUL
STEVENS.
THAT'S HORRIBLE.
>> GLOVES AND ALL FOR $20, I
THINK THEY'D LIKE THE REAL RUTH
BADER TO HAVE A GUARANTEE LIKE
THAT.
THEY ARE DOING MULTIPLE
INCARNATION IN LEGO3, WE'LL SHOW
YOU THOSE.
THIS MAY LOOK FAMILIAR.
THE LAURA INGRAHAM LEGO.
LAURA IN SPACE.
THIS ONE REALLY, THIS LIKENESS
IS AMAZING.
>> Laura: THAT'S HORRIBLE.
>> THIS IS MY FAVORITE.
>> Laura: WHAT DO I HAVE IN MY
HAND?
>> THOSE ARE YOUR EYES AND LIPS.
>> Laura: THAT'S TERRIFYING.
I SHOULD GO ON A DIET.
>> DON'T GO WAIT IN LINE, FOLKS.
>> Laura: THAT GAVEL THAT RUTH